that stoic demeanor of this keeps this
team very level Olaf the main thing
right now starting backcourt right they
needed out there they were on four five
before that show but there always look
wide because your star player is the
epitome of giving the guy named lil hits
the three and that's his second field
goal tonight trying to close this series
out against Portland's working against
Greg contestant on doesn't matter for
James I'll give you a little look at lil
eight here watch he as he stepped back
that was because out of that oppose his
face he can make those from the lower
yeah no doubt about it that's not it
called him we all goal is if you just
took them right off now see what's
happened once you go back all right he's
going to come averaging three a game
attempts sheet at forty seven percent in
the series from the three-ball
oh there's one thing over here appears
let me though valve you doubted us
before he just showed you on you pick
him roll he's gonna size it up now you
know what I'm just gonna stay behind if
you guys are going to try to trap me as
I come off get it up over columns and
seven Pete what's up with ten to the
game Willard in rhythm
another one he's got 12 and Lillard is 6
for 10 in the three-ball and it says
great that he is